la côte nord est une région éloignée et
enclavée c'était l'état 900 km de
Montréal et blanc Sablon qui n'est même
pas relié à la route 138 est à 1500 km à
vol d'oiseau on nous donne pas de choix
on n'a pas d'opportunités on est
vraiment pris on est temps que lavé ici
à cette île c'est prouventable
prendre l'avion ici et souvent
incontournable mais c'est aussi souvent
une aventure à l'aéroport de cette île
on croise Sylvie aimond qui doit souvent
aller à Québec cet hiver la liaison est
vraiment
époque on réserve puis lorsqu'on arrive
où on vérifie le vol avant de partir
c'est annulé on peut postier là-dessus
pourquoi c'est à ce point pas fiable on
nous le dit pas on subit les contrecoups
tout simplement il faut être résilient
c'est encore plus compliqué pour Sonia
manger qui habite elle un des villages
de la Basse Côte Nord ou aucune route ne
se rend elle prend l'hélicoptère puis un
petit avion pour aller à cette île des
fois j'ai vu est arrêté est obligé
d'attendre quatre jours de temps pour
voyager soit par la météo ils ont
souvent aussi des bruits mécaniques ou
autres qu'on connaît pas la vraie alpha
les vraies réponses là mais on atteint
puis à ce moment-là faut payer nos à
les élus de la côte nord ont tous eux
aussi leurs histoires à raconter et il
s'impatiente je prends l'avion à
Montréal
je sais même pas quand tu vas partir de
ce type moi j'en ai pas assez il y a pas
une fois que je suis revenu dans mes
voyages à Québec ou à Montréal que je
suis revenu en avion je suis revenu en
voiture
cette situation selon eux ni à l'image
de la région qui fait déjà face à une
baisse de population d'année en année
c'est un enjeu qui était économique
également qui a des répercussions alors
lorsque les gens dans les médias
entendent parler que c'est si
catastrophique de se déplacer pour venir
sur la conteneur ça laisse pas ça des
gens d'extérieur ou les gens qui sont
natifs de cette île à revenir s'établir
Air Canada plus important de compagnie à
desservir la région n'a pas voulu nous
accorder d'entrevue par courriel
l'entreprise affirme qu'elle planifie
son horaire de façon prudente suite à la
pandémie cela dit pour diverses raisons
telles que problèmes mécaniques une
inclamente et autres certains vols
doivent être annulés cela reste
l'exception par rapport au nombre de
vols que nous exploitons l'autre
problème décrié sur la côte nord et le
prix élevé des billets région éloignée
il faut être patient
il faut payer on peint très cher un
aller-retour Montréal sétile pendant la
première semaine de mars pouvait coûter
jusqu'à 1000 dollars au tarif économique
un aller-retour Montréal Blanc-Sablon
jusqu'à 3000 dollars notre gouvernement
et le gouvernement qui a pris les choses
en main en offrant de en mettant sur
pied dans le fond un programme d'accès
aérien aux régions c'est à dire le
fameux 500$ le billet à 500 dollars
aller-retour mais ce programme qui n'est
pas accessible aux travailleurs ne donne
pas les résultats escomptés au 31
janvier seulement 28% des
9800 billets disponibles avaient été
vendus en huit mois c'est bon c'est sûr
mais s'il y a pas d'avion disponible ça
sert à quoi
améliorer la fiabilité et la garantie
des vols et le nombre de vols c'est un
programme pour lequel on va tirer des
analyses après cette année
d'exploitation là et pour lequel on va
apporter des améliorations Québec a créé
un comité pour améliorer le transport
aérien en région ces conclusions sont
prévues en avril 2024 ici jean-Sébastien
Cloutier Radio-Canada Montréal